إحدى الأمهات في الخارج لتعطيل صناعة الحفاضات ،
اسمها هو shazi visram
جيدًا ، المشكلة مع الحفاظات هي أنها عمل قذر
وقد كان عملاً قذرًا
لفترة طويلة حقًا
ولهذا السبب أسست هذه الغرفة
شركة Healthy baby وهي أول شركة تقوم بإنشاء EWG
حفاضات معتمدة من ewg تمثل
مجموعة العمل البيئية وهي منظمة غير
ربحية متخصصة في
البحث والدعوة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمواد الكيميائية السامة التي يجلس طفلك فيها
في حفاضات في السنوات الثلاث الأولى من حياته
عندما يتطور دماغه بشكل أساسي
إلى أقصى حد تقريبًا و  لماذا
نغير الحفاضات هو أنه
شيء نحتاجه جميعًا كآباء والأمهات كما
تعلمون لدينا حفاضات من القماش ولكن لدينا أيضًا حفاضات من القماش ولكن لدينا أيضًا
كل
شيء يلامس بشرة الطفل مصنوع من
النباتات لذا فقد حظرنا 2300
مكون وكان أطفالها  من ألهمها
ابني هو أكبر معلم لي
وشُخصت عاقلًا بالتوحد
ولديها اثنان كان يتطوران عادةً ،
تحدث أنه رقص ، وأشار إلى أنه غنى
و  n فجأة بدا الأمر وكأنه
بدأ يفقد المعالم
وحتى يومنا هذا كان
أمامه حياة صعبة للغاية ، ثم
رأيت ابنتي
وفعلت كل ما يمكنني فعله
بالمعرفة التي كانت لدي لأنني
شعرت بالقوة  وتعلمت الكثير عن
كل ثانية من التطور وكل
مرحلة وكيف يتطور الدماغ وكيف
يمكننا إعادة توصيل أدمغتنا وكيف يمكننا
بالفعل تقوية أدمغتنا منذ
البداية ، كما أن آشا هي
شعار الطفل السليم هي هي
مصدر الإلهام لما نقوم به في هذه الغرفة
ليس غريباً إعادة اختراع
صناعة للأفضل في عام 2003 ، فقد
أطلقت عائلة سعيدة
أصبحت أكثر العلامات التجارية نجاحًا في أغذية الأطفال العضوية
في الولايات المتحدة التي
باعت الشركة بعد عقد من الزمن أشعر أنني أحبها
لقد عثرت على شيء
يمكن تحقيقه ويمكن أن يساعد في الواقع العائلات الأخرى.
طفل في حياة صحية إذا قمنا
ببعض الأشياء المعينة ، لكن الطفل السليم
لا يقتصر فقط على حفاضات الشركة
التي تصف نفسها على أنها تقدم الدماغ ،
فقد ابتكرت منتجات تنظيف نباتية
حتى مجموعة من
فيتامينات ما قبل وبعد الولادة ، وهذا التركيز
يجعل 34 دعامة سطحية  لذلك عندما تقوم
بالرش من زجاجة بلاستيكية ،
فإنك تقوم برش بلاستيك prac على
سطح يأكل منه طفلك
أو تقوم بتنظيف ألعابه
بشيء يحتوي على مواد كيميائية في
البلاستيك ثم يقومون بوضعه  إنه
في أفواههم ، أعني أنني لست هنا
لإخافة أي شخص ، لكنني هنا لأقول مهلاً ، يمكننا
أن نفعل أفضل
ميليسا ، أحد الأشياء التي أحبها حقًا
للطفل السليم هو تغليفهم ، لذلك
لديهم بالفعل أنشطة
وألعاب هناك  الصناديق التي
تأتي بها الحفاضات بحيث يكون لدى الأمهات والآباء الجدد
أشياء يفعلونها
مع أطفالهم في تلك السنة الأولى
أو الثانية من العمر